on loan from sports illustrated their
senior nba writer joining us from the
bubble
he is chris mannix who joins us on the
program hi chris what do you have for me
today
uh well i'm pretty much at my low point
health health and cleanliness wise why
is that that
uh showers are not daily here
in the bubble um and meals
meals have consisted for me largely up
they've got in the the snack room this
giant
bowl of those little peanut butter cups
i think i'm averaging like 15 a day
like it's a it's a lot that i'm putting
in my system so
that's where we're at then have you done
laundry
they actually have a laundry service so
there's a bag that you can just drop
in a bin so good that's for a new yorker
you know that's the fluff and fold is is
much needed
all right let me talk to you about the
zion williamson situation because
it felt like the nba went out of its way
to get the pelicans at least
into orlando into the bubble and when i
watched
the first game i didn't understand the
minutes
restriction there and if you're going to
be smart then why don't you have him you
be used for valuable minutes maybe at
the end of a game
i don't understand the three four minute
burst i think you're more apt to get
hurt in a three or four minute burst
trying to do too much
then if i give you seven minutes where
you can relax out there on the floor
then i watched him yesterday against the
clippers and i'm thinking
send him home it it just it this
is a disservice i think to him and i
think new orleans has to be honest about
this
where do you stand with uh the whole
zion situation
yeah a couple things one when zion came
back
i was at the pelicans practice and was
talking to david griffin there and
they pelicans officials have made it
clear that the zion
situation with his minutes has nothing
to do with the knee injury
that cost him all but 19 games this year
it has to do with the 13 days
that he missed with the family emergency
so if it was any player i think they'd
probably
operate under the same protocols because
of the fear
of any kind of soft tissue injury and i
would think obviously that fear gets
ramped up even more when you're talking
about your franchise player i do agree
with you
when it comes to the minutes situation
where
if you're gonna play zion like 15
minutes again this is really only
applicable for
uh the first game the game against the
clippers i mean they were blown out that
game was over early on
but against the jazz you've got to time
these minutes
you can get him back in for the final
five minutes
of that game boston's had kind of
similar problems you know
adjusting the minutes for kemba walker
it might have cost them their first game
against milwaukee
and last night they kept kemp out the
entire fourth quarter
of their game against the blazers so i
think where you could argue with the
pelicans
is if you're going to play these short
bursts why not play them in
consequential minutes
and divvy it up so you make sure that
zion can be out there in crunch time
situations
what do you take away best team so far
you've seen is who
i mean the bucks looked pretty good
right up until the end of the game last
night
um so there's that i mean i i thought
coming into this that the clippers
might struggle because they've had so
many guys
missing but i mean they've been great i
mean they were on fire
from three-point range uh in their last
game and that's something i wondered
about that team coming in every team
would they be as efficient from
three-point range after all this time
off but
the clippers playing this well without
you know montrez tarot and without
lou williams in the mix this point with
their guys starting to get their legs i
i don't think right now that's a
question of which team is playing the
best it's which team looks like they're
going to play
playing the best and the clippers are
interesting i'll throw one other team at
you too because i've watched them
a couple of times i mean houston
houston's wild to watch
i mean they really they were out
rebounded last night by 29
that's the kind of stuff you see in like
billy madison like you don't see that
in an actual basketball game out
rebounded by 29
but because they were so good at getting
in the paint
and driving and kicking they took 61
three-pointers that's 17 more than their
season average
and you know i saw daryl mori leaving
the building and daryl was like man we
didn't even make what we usually make we
only made 21 of them
in that game so the rockets if they can
continue to get
great dribble penetration from hardin
westbrook there's no reason to believe
that they can't
i mean they're going to be a handful to
try to keep off the scoreboard
if they can win against the best team
you know record wise in the nba
by giving up a rebounding edge of 29
there's a lot of teams they're going to
have that have a lot of problems with
them yeah that was my outlier you know
when you start to think about the bucks
and the clippers and lakers and i said
you don't want to face houston because
they had the x factors there with
westbrook and hardin
and you get gordon back and it's just
it's a different
type of team that you're a style that
nobody else is playing the way they play
it and that's why i think houston is is
one of those teams
uh dan on on that one more thing that
like
i think teams got to adjust to the
rockets and do what the jazz did
last year last year the jazz remember
they put rudy gobert on
on westbrook and just go bears kind of
like sat there
and dared westbrook to score 50 on
mid-range jump shots
it's you're going to put up he's going
to give you a big stat line
but if you trade mid-range contested or
mid-range russell westbrook twos
for uncontested threes you take that all
day long i didn't understand milwaukee's
strategy of like just
throwing dante divincenzo and george
hill to the fire and letting them play
westbrook straight up i mean i think you
got to do something unorthodox
and dare westbrook to beat you from the
mid-range what do you make of the lakers
so far
i mean so far so good and you know not
the it's certainly not
a they're not missing avery bradley as
much as some people thought
uh that they might davis you know at
least in the opener he played
fantastic lebron's still getting his
legs under i mean they they're kind of
they are what what i expect them to be
they don't look anything less
they're not the team we saw right before
the pandemic but they don't look like
they've
they've struggled they don't look
they're like they're out of shape uh
they look like the favorite in the west
right now at least the co-favorite
talking to chris spanick sports
illustrated senior senior nba writer
joining us from the bubble
what are you hearing about next season
you know there's a lot of talk already
about
how this is going to work next season
and
right now the big thing for the nba is
getting in all 82 games
you know they want the 82 games at a
minimum for the television revenue
the union doesn't want an 82 game season
that starts on december 1st which the
nba would like to do to get it back to
its regular schedule right now so that's
kind of the first domino to fall if the
nba comes off
the 82 game season i think you could
have
a 50 60 game season that starts december
even january because at that point it
doesn't really matter the question
that the league is working through right
now is how do you start that season and
some of the gm's that have been on these
calls with the league
have told me that one of the working
ideas right now
is to have several bubbles that are set
up it's pretty obvious dan the bubbles
are the only thing that works i mean the
nba's is working soccer hockey
everything else is not working at this
point so the nba
is already kind of in the conception
stage of maybe five or six
bubbles that they could put together you
wouldn't stay there for the entire for
the duration
you might stay in the bubble a month and
maybe take a week or two off
there's a lot of of of things to work
through there but
right now the the way that the nba is
looking at it is that you might have to
have
several or more than that bubbles to get
these teams in to start the season
wow uh i brought this up earlier in the
show
like how many players are must see tv in
the nba
because you start to run down the list
and and i had about
five or six and i'm probably not as
lenient as you are i said lebron
i said harden i said doncic um
steph curry went healthy
durant i'm kind of on the border with
that i don't think the greek freak is
must see
tv russell westbrook used to be anthony
davis is not must-see tv
and now i'm taking i'm taking teams out
of this i'm just looking at an
individual
kawhi is not not must-see tv certainly
not during the regular season
trae young is a little more musty tv
than some of these other players in my
opinion
damien lillard is somebody that i love
watching
i don't know if you have anybody else
that like
do we have five seven or am i missing
out on somebody here
no you you got to the guy i was going to
mention at the end damian lillard i mean
he's
he's must see tv like he you know he
against boston
um the other day you know the celtics
had like a 10 point lead or something
and damien lithard
has marcus smart on him for most of the
game and marcus smart is probably a
first-team all-defensive
all-defensive player and lillard just
goes off he pulls jump shots from
i mean steph curry shoots these long
shots damien little seems to shoot just
as many
and is just as efficient you know from
that range he's the guy that
when i see him that's kind of what what
i do here i go to a lot of practices but
i kind of circle the games and the
players
that i want to see go at it and lillard
i think he's got his next game is coming
up against uh
against houston you know lillard versus
russell westbrook once again
i mean that's watching that largely
because of damien lillard because of
what he does
and what he's capable of doing at any
point in the game he's not afraid man
and he's going to have a chip on his
shoulder his entire career
if he stays in portland because you sort
of forget
and and you look he goes to weber state
like it's just one of those careers
you're going to look back and go
you can put those stats up against
anybody
and he's he's really that and they are
they are a really
interesting team because like i look at
nurkic
and collins and them coming back and
that's a huge boost to them but i
watching them i can't help but wonder
what they'd be with trevor ariza i mean
carmelo has been fine
you know he's been against boston he was
efficient from three but he still
you know jacks up these long twos and
commits silly fouls because he's not
quick enough anymore to be a consistent
three if that team
had trevor ariza my confidence and their
ability to not only make the playoffs
but do something
in the playoffs would be a little bit
higher but watching them you can see
they miss that kind of versatile
defensive wing
that ariza is is the commissioner in the
bubble
he was at some point i believe he was in
the bubble for the opener
i don't know if he's still here so he's
allowed to come and go
i would imagine and i'm supposed to
speak to him at some point but i would
imagine
that what he's doing is what a lot of
you know team officials or owners or
whatever are doing and that's continue
to be tested
every day while you're off campus and
when you get into the bubble
you can you can have a shorter
quarantine period uh because you've been
tested all throughout so maybe it's the
what the teams were at like 36 hours or
48 hours
when they first got into the boat enjoy
the uh candy bars
it's gross dan really gross
i can't wait to talk to you in like two
months i'm not see here's the thing i'm
not sure
if i'm going to be 20 pounds heavier or
20 pounds lighter because
there's no pizza which is my always my
go-to but there's unlimited candy
so i'm not sure which i gained more from
what about beer you can order off campus
they'll
they'll deliver for you um like a
cabinet can you order a cake not a keg
okay you order cases of beer but i've
done but the problem is also
shout out to the league for not doing
this there's no bar here like
sports writers without a bar is
i don't i don't even know what the
comparison is like it's like missing a
leg they would rather go out
go without oxygen before they would
a bar some of us some of us sit by the
pool with like
you know a 30 rack like we're in high
school
drinking hair so it's what it is all
right
thank you chris you got it that's chris
manning sports illustrated senior nba
writer